Have you ever thought about standing for a Community Board?
It’s a great way to serve your community
and with the local body elections coming up, we’re fishing for new candidates.
So what’s involved?
If elected – the decisions and recommendations
you’ll make, will benefit your local community.
You’ll attend monthly meetings, community
events
and may be involved with various community groups, depending on your interests and availability.
You could expect to spend roughly three to five hours a week in the role.
So make a difference, nominations are open now.
Grab the form or find out more at waimakariri.govt.nz/vote2019